هذه الليلة ، دكتاتور كوريا الشمالية البالغ من العمر 37 عامًا
يضع بصمته مع الرئيس الأمريكي الجديد
ربما في محاولة لجذب انتباه جو بايدن
بعيدًا عن فلاديمير بوتين
بعد أسبوع الرئيس على
المسرح العالمي ،
أعلن كيم جونغ أون أنه
يجب إعداد عرض أسعار لكوريا الشمالية لكليهما.  الحوار
والمواجهة مع الولايات المتحدة ،
مضيفًا أنه يجب أن يكون مستعدًا تمامًا
للمواجهة ،
ويأتي ذلك بعد شهور من قيام كيم
بتوجيه تهديدات ضمنية ضد الولايات المتحدة
، وما أسماه كيم سياسة أمريكا العدائية
تجاه كوريا الشمالية ،
يقول أحد المحللين إن هذا يمكن أن يكون خطوة كلاسيكية من
قبل
كيم ليس فقط  لفت انتباه جو بايدن
إليه ولكن أيضًا للاستفادة من
ترسانته النووية ومحاولة انتزاع التنازلات
من البيت الأبيض ،
إنها قائمة طويلة من الأشياء التي
يريدون ليس فقط نهاية
التدريبات العسكرية في كوريا الجنوبية
ولكن نهاية التحالف الكوري الجنوبي الأمريكي
انسحاب جميع
القوات الأمريكية والتخلي عن جميع
العقوبات الدولية والعقوبات الأمريكية حتى الآن قال فريق بايدن
إنه يريد ذلك  البناء
على الاتفاقات التي أبرمها كيم مع
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
لسحب برنامج الأسلحة النووية لكوريا الشمالية
خلال تلك الفترة
، كان ترامب وكيم معروفين
بعلاقتهما الحميمة ، حيث يتبادلان
الرسائل المتدفقة التي كان ترامب يتفاخر بها
، ثم وقعنا في الحب ولكن
اتفاقيات كيم  مع ترامب كان غامضًا
، وأشار الرئيس بايدن إلى أنه
يتخذ موقفًا أكثر تشددًا بشأن احتمال
الجلوس مع كيم ،
لكن المحللين يقولون إنه منذ تلك المحادثات مع
ترامب وحتى أثناء الوباء ،
قام كيم ببناء برنامج أسلحته سراً ،
وقد اختبرت كوريا الشمالية صواريخ قصيرة المدى
في
الأشهر الأخيرة لم تختبر الصواريخ بعيدة المدى
مؤخرًا ، ولكن في استعراض في أكتوبر في
بيونغ يانغ
، عرض النظام ما يقول الخبراء إنه
صاروخ باليستي جديد عابر للقارات
قادر على الوصول إلينا ، ويقول المحللون
إن الديكتاتور من المرجح أن يختبر إطلاق هذا
السلاح في
نهاية المطاف.  سيتعين عليه اختبار ما إذا كان
يريد
المضي قدمًا في البرنامج نفسه على t  من ناحية أخرى
، يدرك كيم جونغ أون تمامًا أن
اختبار الصواريخ بعيدة المدى
هو في الأساس خط أحمر كبير
قد لا تتعامل معه إدارة بايدن
جيدًا ،
حيث يراقب محللو المخابرات من
سيول إلى واشنطن
عن كثب مظهر كيم
تحديدًا وزنه.
تشير مقارنات الفيديو جنبًا إلى جنب إلى أن كيم يبدو
أنحف الآن مما كان عليه العام الماضي في
الخريف
الماضي.وقال مسؤولون في المخابرات الكورية الجنوبية
للمشرعين إنهم يعتقدون أن وزن كيم قد
تضخم إلى أكثر من 300 رطل في عام 2020 ،
لكن صور ساعة يد كيم التي يبلغ وزنها 12 ألف دولار
تظهر في  أحدث
صورة على
اليمين مثبتة الآن على درجة أضيق
مما كانت عليه في المشاهدات السابقة
لماذا يمثل وزن كيم مثل هذه الأولوية بالنسبة
لوكالات المخابرات
لأننا لا نعرف سوى القليل عن
القيادة الكورية الشمالية
ونواياها ولا نعرف من
سيخلفه  إذا مات فجأة
ولكن إذا حدث
ذلك ، يعتقد معظم المحللين أن
أخت كيم الصغرى كيم يو جونغ بيلي
تبلغ من العمر 33 عامًا تقريبًا من المحتمل أن
تتولى السلطة مكانتها
وقد ازدادت مسؤولياتها في
السنوات الأخيرة ، فهل
ستنجو كما يشير أحد المحللين في
كل مرة كان هناك
خلافة
في نظام كيم ، توقع الكثير من مراقبي كوريا الشمالية
ذلك  ستفشل لكن 70 عامًا في عائلة كيم
ما زالت سائدة